The terrifying Hellrasier saga, surrounding
Pinhead and his nefarious band of Cenobites,
continues in Hellraiser: Judgment with more
puzzle boxes, hapless victims, and, of course,
a few trips to 55 Ludovico Place.
This time, there's a serial slayer on the
loose in the earthly realm, doling out justice
for various violations of the Ten Commandments
as some sort of sick scheme to win God's favor.
Meanwhile, Pinhead and his pals have been
exacting their own brand of justice in Hell
— and when the two worlds collide, well,
there's you-know-what to pay.
"Evil seeks evil."
Let's take a look at how the story draws everything
together and sets up the next round of hell-raising.
Harsh judgment
Pinhead's new right-hand man - er, thing - is
the most interesting addition to the film.
Called the Auditor, this slashed-face baddie
begins the process of eternal judgment on
Pinhead's behalf.
"I'm a man for whom pain is nothing more than
a common currency."
Naturally, this is all very gross for everyone
involved.
After the Auditor types up a human's confession,
another sidekick called the Assessor chows
down on the pages and regurgitates them up
for a trio of jurors, who rifle through the
contents and then render their verdict.
Punishment then begins with a disgusting saliva
bath before the subject is sent to the Butcher
and the Surgeon for some key rearrangements.
So, yeah, it's foul in every imaginable way.
And whoever ends up at the Cotton House is
in for quite an unpleasant surprise.
Unless...
Detective with a dark side
At first, we're led to believe that Detective
Sean Carter is just a man who's far too into
his job of hunting down serial killers.
He comes home late to his angry wife, can't
seem to stay away from work, and is even being
investigated by the case's newest pair of
eyes.
Detective Christine Edgerton is here to help,
but she also believes he might be suffering
PTSD from his war service and maybe dabbling
in drugs or alcohol.
His brother David, who is somehow his partner
in crime-fighting, thinks he's a rational
and good person and gladly follows him down
whatever rabbit hole his investigations take
them through.
By the end of the film, however, we find out
that looks have been very deceiving when it
comes to Sean.
"It is a terrible ponderous chain you are
making."
He's actually the one who's taken on the mantle
of righteous death-dealer, slaughtering people
who run afoul of the Ten Commandments in pretty
much any way, shape, or form.
Between him underlining the same Charles Dickens
quotes from the crime scenes to his obsession
with Ecclesiastes, which roughly translates
to the very name of the man they're after,
he implicates himself pretty well along the
way.
"What was it he said, only God can judge me.
God'll judge the righteous."
And his crimes are unspeakable.
He saws off the hands, eyeballs, and teeth
of some teens while they're still alive simply
because they'd committed petty theft; he surgically
implants a woman's womb with her still-living
dog because she says in a phone video that
she worships the animal.
It's so bad that even the Assessor can't stomach
the taste of his confessions.
And yet he manages to escape Judgment — twice
— because of a demand from on high.
The powers that be
It seems like Pinhead holds the ultimate authority
over how the guilty are treated in his domain.
But when the archangel Jophiel shows up and
insists that David be sent back to Earth to
finish his "work" — which, at first, we
think is just solid policing — Pinhead's
team has no choice but to concede.
"Do you understand who is in charge?
Just let him go."
Pinhead still sends his stitch twins along
to haunt his nightmares, but he mostly steers
clear of Sean.
After Sean brings himself back to Pinhead's
realm again, though, in hopes of trading his
brother and wife for his own soul being cleared,
Pinhead and his Auditor refuse to bargain
with him or Jophiel.
They're ready to move on to the punishment
phase… and chaining Sean's brother and wife
up to a state of eternal suffering won't satisfy
their bloodlust.
Jophiel wants him to be sent back to Earth
to carry on with his Commandment slaughters
so more people will turn to the Almighty for
protection.
This makes Sean believe his plan is falling
into place, but Jophiel informs him that he's
not getting any absolution out of this arrangement.
He'll still be Pinhead's property after it's
all said and done, but she just wants to buy
him more time for his bad deeding.
The trouble is, Pinhead's grown wary of blindly
obeying Jophiel's demands.
The final judgment
At first, Pinhead obliges Jophiel's request
to return Sean to the living so he can score
the good side some souls.
But when Sean regains consciousness, he's
immediately waxed by Detective Edgerton, who's
now figured out he's the big bad they've been
looking for.
Sean's instant demise puts him back in Pinhead's
clutches, for good this time— and that angers
Jophiel, who threatens to bring down the wrath
of her boss for his insolence.
Pinhead decides he's got nothing to lose,
though.
He's already in Hell and was basically built
to endure such suffering, so how much worse
could it get for him?
Not only does he ignore her warnings, Pinhead
also proceeds to throw the angel into his
chains and lets them rip her to shreds.
Even the Auditor knows his boss has made a
massive mistake.
As he points out, Jophiel was the angel who
banished Adam and Eve from the Garden of Eden,
and if she could do it to them, she could
do something similar to Pinhead.
Just as all those he's judged have awoken
to the harsh consequences of their mistakes,
the last scene finds a humanized version of
Pinhead banished from his realm of "sweet
suffering" and sent to the mortal realm.
Meanwhile, the post-credits scene opens up
the door for the Auditor to take over altogether,
as he's shown in Hanover, Germany, welcoming
two unsuspecting missionaries into his lethal
lair.
"Two.
And it isn't even a Tuesday."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!